i'm uh
ed pegg jr and i'm going to be talking
about algebraic tilings
there's my name and email address there
and here's an abstract for what i'm
going to be talking about
we we have a whole bunch of
substitution tiling systems that were
unknown
and i'm going to show how i built one of
them out of this polynomial here
x to the third equals x squared plus one
and from that i'll talk about other
things with
algebraic numbers and how to use very
significant coordinates
to do tiling systems with those
and then i'll use those that the same
techniques to do a whole bunch of
other tiling systems
let's see and i'm looking at the
chat here and other participants looks
like we've got
quite a crowd here
so here is the super golden ratio here
also known as psy or the niryama kyle
constant
uh and if you're familiar with
fibonacci's rapid rabbits
an indian mathematician asked a similar
question about
how cows would would go and the the
ratio is
called the near yama cow constant or the
super golden ratio
and this is the value here and it's the
solution to this
polynomial i'm going to be looking at
this root here one of the complex roots
and if you take powers of that fifth
root
here's the zeroth powers at zero 1
here's the first power second power
third power fourth power
you just take this and look at those
first
five powers and you get those points
and the fifth point here i just
basically take the center
of zero one and rotate four to get this
fifth point
and with those six points
you can build these three similar
polygons quadrilaterals
and these happen to have areas that are
in the ratio of the super golden ratio
this is also known as a rousey fractal
and using the same coordinate systems
using
the various powers like this we can get
a
a cow fractal out of this this i call
this the
the cal fractal triangle and
if you take the original cow triangle
you can divide it into two
smaller cow triangles this rousey
fractal was known
but this wasn't i'm just doing
pure uh quadrilaterals here
with this substitution system and we get
back
after an infinite number of steps you
get the rousey
cal triangle fractal
so how did i do this let's go back to
these points again
so here are the six points
now in the algebraic number field
of the super golden ratio this
doesn't work you get a whole bunch of
errors in this mess
but a classic trick in physics if at
first it doesn't work
try zero one or squaring well it turns
out that
that trick is all that's necessary to
get this to work
beautifully so i call this the sine
square
technique so i take the sine and then
the square
and then everything is in that algebraic
field of the super golden ratio
and here are the algebraic coordinates
of that point
so for this first value here you can
consider this as
minus this is actually divided by four
minus one fourth times the super golden
ratio to zero
half to the times
the super golden ratio to the power of 1
and minus 1
4 times the super golden ratio to the
power 2.
all these these are the algebraic
coordinates
in that system and after finding that
this was really useful i thought
i should make a function out of that and
so there's a resource function called
square root space and basically this
either
squares or takes the square root but
preserves the sine
so i'm not sure if there's a better name
for this or if this
general method is known but i found it
to be quite
powerful for example
you can divide up a triangle into six
similar triangles
and android zach found this smaller
triangle here
and i extended it to include this
triangle here and then you get the same
triangle back
to make a substitution center this
happens to be
in the space of the plastic constant and
if you look at
geometric scene you'll see that this is
one of the examples that we give
in the documentation so you start with
the
root which is the plastic constant you
take these algebraic coordinates
you plug those all in and you get this
triangle which is this the same triangle
divided
up into six smaller copies
that are in the ratio of the plastic
constant
this system doesn't work without
squaring
you can do the same thing with this snub
cube
you have the technology constant here is
the root
here are the algebraic coordinates the
polygons you get the snub cube
the sub dodecahedron you take the tetra
nachi constant
substitute in the golden ratio for one
here the
algebraic coordinates since it's a order
six all the coordinates
in the algebraic system have six parts
that all happen to be integers and you
get the snub dot decahedron back
the canonical tetragonal anti-wedge
hexahedron
is in this root the
for canonical that means that if you
take the unit sphere
you can express the polygon so that all
the
edges are tangent to the unit sphere
and the same happens to to go for the
dual of that polyhedron the tetragonal
anti-wedge hexahedron is self-dual so
i've got
two copies here and the
the edges of the dual and the original
happen to be perpendicular to each other
in this form
dividing a square into acute
similar triangles you can do that with
48 triangles as found by these guys
and everything is in the root space of
the square root of three
the last sporadic exception to the
orchard problem
is in this root so you have
52 rows of three with 19
trees with three of them at infinity and
the algebraic coordinates
are are these values here
the discovering problem to perfectly
cover a
a circle with 12 discs this is the
optimal solution
and you use this root here
these are the algebraic coordinates
the klobby triangle uh if the
the largest squares all have the same
area this is known as the kalabi
triangle
you use this root these nice algebraic
values
and there's there's the the triangle
the unit distant graph problem
so you have the golem graph
and the moser spindle everything can be
done in
in route 33. aubry de gray really liked
this
demonstration um which i have here moser
spindles
golem graphs this demonstration here
where i have a whole
bunch of different copies of the moser
spindle on the and the golem graph
he really liked that and had this idea
of extending this with
also the values root seven and root five
and i said uh you probably won't go get
anywhere with that
i happen to be wrong and he solves the
hadridge or nelson problem which is a
long unfold problem in the mathematics
it's a with the biggest result in graphs
in the past two years
and i happen to be wrong about it but he
used my demo to help get there
the chromatic brace square uses that
root
and i've got hundreds of other examples
of where the square roots
uh worked really well in algebraic
spaces
for example all n-gons or the 17 gone
here are the values it's a it's a
order eight root this time so
all the coordinates have eight parts
but they all happen to be integers
everything works nicely
the discriminant happens to be 17 to the
power of 7.
and another factor i found in this is
when the discriminant has small factors
it tends to work very nicely in
geometric problems
so it's like magic this trick
in physics where if you're in doubt it
helps to square things
well it really works in this in this
example in
in within algebra now in
tiling you need to repeat coordinates
so the best way i found to do that was
to use
very significant coordinates or ariel
coordinates
and that has these properties you start
with n base points defining a triangle
or tetrahedron
and you let that shape
be defined as having area one then you
substitute a given point p
for each of the n base points in turn
and you calculate the signed areas
with with the other point dropped out
and this
this code here is the same as the very
center coordinate code but i also
uh have a conversion to and from
added in and for an example with
pericentric coordinates
suppose you have this equilateral
triangle
as the outside triangle and here's
here's the point here
so we say this triangle has area one
and we have an example point here
which has very centric coordinates of
one-sixth one-half
one-third i found it's useful just to
multiply everything by
the denominator and that way you get
integers on top
so one-sixth one-half one-third the
actual coordinates
are here and if you convert
with this triangle to very centric
coordinates you get one-sixth one-half
one-third
and you can go back by multiplying that
by the triangle and you get the
coordinate back
this sort of back and forth system i
found is very useful
and the barycentric coordinates are
often
beautiful in these in these problems
for example putting 25 points and 18
lines of five points
everything happens to have a constraint
system and a root
so here are the six points again
we can we can consider the triangle as
points one
two three so here's point
five the actual coordinates are the
messy root object there
but if we go to square root space you
get this nice set of
rational values and the very center
coordinates are also
messy but the very secret but the square
root space version
also happens to be nice i haven't
figured out a way of using that last
part yet i have this idea there might be
a way of skipping a whole bunch of steps
in
algebra that takes the nice integer
values and skips a whole bunch of sets
and gives other nice
integer values but so far i haven't been
able to find that
it'd be nice because it would make
things much much much faster
but so far it doesn't exist
so a complete tiling system
has a root a set of algebraic points
in that root some polygon replacement
rules
uh polygon types for example
um if you have a type one polygon it
splits into
another type 1 polygon and a type 2
polygon
this takes if you have a type 2 polygon
it goes to a type 3 polygon if you have
a type 3 polygon it goes to a type 1
polygon
so this is all that's necessary to know
for this particular timeline system
which i call psi quad
so here's the tiling system in
action
so for the code
you take the tiling system you find the
very centric mapping
you map the polygon
so
[Music]
if we start with
polygons we can return the set of
points in their messy forms
likes like so but we can convert them
with square root space to nice
algebraic coordinates and
the the polygon
step is basically a list of polygons in
each state
based on their their vertis so for
example vertex 1
is 1 0 and so on
so this is another thing sort of like
a graphics complex
the most powerful values are these
uh the persona numbers um
these last four here are all episode
numbers
and i added in two because it has
another property
these were the most powerful i found
these all had the property of
being sums of their own infinite
reciprocal powers
and i've got a demonstration that i did
on peso numbers which you can look at
later so
each of these is is uh the sum of an
infinite series of
reciprocals of itself and these are the
the polynomials involved and here's a
little diagram of how the roots place
they all happen to have on tiling
properties
for example if you take an ordinary
sheet of a4 paper with
area 200 you can divide it
into other rectangles with the same
aspect ratio that have
all the values of either a square number
or twice a square number
to get this perfect packing that's uh
for 2 2 has that property
the super golden ratio has this property
the golden ratio has that property and
the
plastic constant has that property
and all of them can self-express his
infinite series
two with similar triangles uh
this triangle up here has one half the
area
one-fourth one-eighth one-sixteenth
here's
the golden ratio done with similar
triangles
the super golden ratio was similar
triangle fractals
and the plastic constant with similar
fractals
i had an intuition that there were
undiscovered single triangle
substitution systems for each of those
values
and it turns out i was correct here they
are
so while i was doing this roger penrose
happened to won the nobel prize in
physics
uh for some reason it was for
for gravitation but uh he's very
interested in both tiling systems and
gravity
and of course we can use uh our our
little program here to
make the penrose rom system
another person who was very interested
in gravity was on johan kepler
who did the precursor to couplers work
with this tiling system and
roger has mentioned that he did use this
as the basis for for his own tiling
system
and i've coded up dozens and dozens of
different
tiling systems and simple forms here's
psi quad here
with you have the root the
the vertices and so on
i've also added some new ones in the
into this just recently
so here is an example here's here's one
with the plastic constant
let's see the labyrinth tiling
one i just recently added was that was
the dog fractal because it starts
looking like a poodle after a while
here's the birds and bees tiling system
and the psi
quad system which is the one i've is
is based on the the points i've
mentioned
i've gotten this to be much faster i
just put in an update today
let's see
i think if you look at the demonstration
site now you'll see the the latest
version
so some things to do here's a 3d
uh 3d fractal tile which breaks up into
eight similar 3d uh
fractal tiles i'm almost certain
there's a lot of nice undiscovered 3d
tiling systems that are out there
and some more undiscovered tiling
systems
um i think except for the exception of
dale walton i found more new
uh substitution tiling systems than
anyone else
dale walton has about three times as
many as as i do
so i'm still trying to catalog all of
his work and
inventory all of them into into my
program
uh doing some further speed up would be
nice
and i did some of that today i'm still
wondering if there's a
pure math way of skipping some steps
but i don't know if that that's that's
possible yet and i'm also wondering what
triangle systems and other geometry con
constructs have algebraic purity of some
sort
where you can skip steps to speed things
up but uh even without that purity
i i think this is a very powerful system
that's already been used to
dissolve uh two unsolved
uh math problems and then i just found a
whole bunch
of new things that had never been
discovered before
so that's my talk i think i can open it
up for questions now
and you can post in either chat or in
the
other place i'm not sure how to
get uh other things here
i'll be glad to go over anything uh
previously
the the notebook for this is in the
files section
if you go to files you should be able to
find the notebook
i used in this talk
uh thailand systems for automata
yes there are some demonstrations
available that that do that
automatically
it'd be nice for me to figure out how to
do more cellular automata within these
tiling systems that would be a good
thing for me to add
many thanks for the for the sign let me
see if i can find something here
so there's that and we've got
this if you go to files
here's where the algebraic tiling talk
is
you should be able to just download it
and it has all the code for this
and at places like
here substitution tilings i just updated
that
this also has my new code in it that's a
much faster and
is much cleaner than my previous
versions
tiling systems to model viral capsid
substructures for that
i think that deals with uh 3d
i haven't figured out a nice way of
finding new tiling systems in 3d
yet um one of the
ways i was able to come up with with
these systems oops
uh back a
few steps here
one of the ways i found out these
systems i started with
finding out ways of doing similar
triangles within a
power structure so this is the square
root of 2 to the power of 0
power of 1 power of 2. the that's what
these numbers here are all powers of the
original root
and i wanted to see how you could go
around a single
point with similar triangles and i
i just wrote a program to brute force do
it
and these particular roots happen to
work really well for example
i found this set of five similar
triangles around the point
and managed to extend this to a to a
tiling system same with
with this here and
this this here so all the
other solutions to that particular
problem didn't work to
tiling systems i need to extend that up
to
three dimensions and figure out how to
surround a point with similar
but i'm not sure how to program that yet
so do feel free to write to me if you
have other tiling systems i've missed
or things i should consider like the
cellular automata in these thailand
systems
i'd love to hear about those and try to
extend this more
and if you are in a geometry system a
graph system
or any other sort of coordinate system
and you're trying to do
things purely algebraically try doing
the sine and square
and see if that makes everything work
better
fin must help the french quilter create
a pattern she calls pasicaglia which is
also a nice
bach work
um gary schultz if you just email me
i'll take a look at it my email is at
the end here
and i'll be glad to take a look at it
the code does automatically color them
and you can go into the code and do a
replacement set of colors if you'd like
this particular uh item up here is
is in the site ifs tiles dot
well it's ifs tile and you'll be able to
find it from that if you do a google
google search
it's a person who's doing a bunch of
research into different
rousey fractals of various sorts
and you're very welcome and i guess that
is we'll wait a few more minutes but
that's
that's uh the end of my talk here